Hey everybody this is the content video
for section 5.12 list comprehensions.
As much as I love list comprehensions
they're a little bit of an
unnecessary idea but don't leave
the video just because I said that
because they're really cool and the
reason I love list comprehensions
is because to me they are a
lot like augmented assignment.
Not necessarily something
you have to do but something
that can make your code
a lot easier to write.
So the idea of list comprehension
is you can take multiple
lines of code that are doing
something like building out a list
and simplify it down to one line
of code. Here's what I mean.
So let's say we have a list and we
want to fill it with six numbers.
So, or sorry, five numbers, a range
of one to six. So we would normally
set it up as four item in range one
to six list dot append item. And
that's great. And then here's our
list. But doing a list comprehension
means that you can do the exact
same thing with one line of code.
And it looks like this. So
instead we would say list
equal item for item in
range, excuse me, one to six.
So there's a kind of syntax to
it, which I don't think they have
here, but I'll write it out in
our code space. So let me jump
over here and we'll do a couple
of examples of list comprehension.
Okay.
I'm a terrible speller, so I have
to sound stuff out as I write
it. All right, so list comprehension.
So let's do an example.
Well, let me let me write
out the syntax for you. So
typically a list comprehension
will look like this.
You've got your list name,
which is the easy part,
right?
List name equals brackets
and then the syntax is item
for item in iterable and
then you can also throw in a
condition if something,
something, something, something,
whatever, right?
So item is the thing that we want in our
list at the end of our creating the list.
For item is setting up an
iterator variable to loop
through something that's
iterable, and then the
condition is optional. So
let me show what I mean.
Let's create a list of colors.
Wait.
Let's create an empty list of colors.
Excuse me.
And normally what we would
maybe do is we would,
well, let's see.
Let's go back to the range
actually, the range activity. So
let's say normally we would fill
a list by saying for i in range.
Let's do 10.
Let's make a list name.
Call it nums equals empty list. For i
in range 10, we'd say nums.append i,
but using a list comprehension we
can say nums, let's call it nums2,
and then we set up our brackets
and then we ask ourselves what
do we want left in this list at
the end of it when we're done?
What do we want this list to look
like? We want it to have numbers
in it so we know we want to put
num in there num for num in range
10.
All right and then if I print it
out let me print out nums and nums
too so you can see that they're
identical in this case all right so
there they both are so it's the same
idea but we're doing it in two lines
of code as opposed or yeah three
lines of code technically as opposed
to one line of code so you might
kind of ask what's the benefit of
doing it well I don't know that
it's necessarily about beneficial
things but it is a stylistic choice
that can often be more convenient.
So let's talk about this
last portion of it if
you have a conditional
statement on the end. So
let's say we want to do
another list comprehension
and we want to let's actually
say we have a list of colors.
What was I think it was list
searching yeah I'm going to take the
list fav colors from the list
searching.py file and I'm just going to
paste it in here, because I don't
want to type all that out again.
Okay,
let's say we want to create
a new list based off of
the list colors, and we only
want to keep colors that
start with the letter G.
Yeah, we'll do that.
Okay, this will get into,
we'll just do it together okay
so we'll say colors okay you know
what we'll just we'll just say
well we only want to list with the
color green in it so green colors
because that's all that it would
give us anyways so that's what
we're going to call the list and
then what do we want to end up in
this list at the end of the day or
at the end of our running this
algorithm we want it to be a color
right now I don't know anything
else really about my my list
comprehension here but I'm gonna say
color and then what am I iterating
through well it's gonna be for and
then I'm gonna say color probably
because I want to create an
iterator variable that's going to
iterate through my list of colors.
So for color in colors, right?
It's almost like once you have
established the variable that you
want left in your list at the end,
you can kind of forget about it.
You can kind of pretend it's not
there. And then you just set up your
for loop right here for color
and colors, right? We're familiar
with that syntax. We know that. And
then this color thing is what I'm
ending up with at the end. So I
both create it and append it into
my list in one line of code. so
for color in colors and then we'll
say if color equals green easy
enough right and then let's print
out green colors and I mean we
already know what we expect to see
green and green so pretty
straightforward well I don't know if it's
straightforward but but this
example maybe is so why use list
comprehension it's fun it's cool I
think it's more convenient and you could
really simplify a lot of your
code that we'll probably come back
to this in a later content video
and i'll show you how you can
simplify more of your code but for
now this is everything that i want
you guys to know about list
comprehension so thank you for watching